yeah man what do you think about this aw
let's get into real quick this James
Davis thing that went down with the girl
with the the young lady had a tweet
making fun of extensions the rapper that
got oh he got killed
extensive extensive yeah and that room
yeah James Davis but that's not the girl
but the girl came out of MIDI Joe oh
also James Davis tweeted her about
something no he called James Davis
called out the girl bright as he was the
one that made the joke she was the one
that made the joke right okay I know I
know the joke I've seen I've seen it
I've seen a bit did you think it was
alright um I I thought I got it but you
know what that joke is like what we were
talking about earlier by saying the
n-word right it's one of those things
worse like this isn't is this necessary
is it really that funny right cuz like
the structure the structure of the joke
I get it it's hilarious right the point
of the point of the joke is funny I
don't know if she executed it the way
like I bet you if I said it it wouldn't
have gotten that that kind of thing
right but so that's important too about
what you look like so this is meek
little white girl
who's making this you know in that kind
of smug liberal way ya know throwing at
the young deceased mix boy under the bus
you know mix Young's anyways just the
way she looks and he got Italian that
needed to be part of she needed to
realize but I again I get I'm not mad at
her for making the joke I get the joke
and I think the structure of the joke is
sound I think I think that it could have
been funnier than the way she did it yes
I get what she was trying to say instead
of like it's not the joke ain't about
him right that's what people need to
understand that jokes not about him or
even making fun of him the joke is about
carrying around $50,000 right that's the
joke the joke is like you know instead
of carrying around $50,000 you know use
venmo yeah that's funny yeah but and so
the fact that the guy was killed because
of the money is a way of emphasizing
that he I'm just intellectualizing the
joke right yeah now let's say she just
didn't executed in a way that it was
like super funny well it shows you how
young people I think to me it feels like
you either
like a millennial generation got more
upset about this probably because they
attach everything just to the person
yeah it's like more of the me culture
it's what I'm saying they don't think
right they don't they hear they just
heard his name and that means it's a
attend a pro he's dead and you're making
fun of him and you're doing other stuff
it's like no yeah she was making fun of
people carrying around a lot of cash
right
use the venmo app and she used him as an
example he's exactly right but it just
wasn't executed in a way that was super
funny right should we play it for the
audience
yellows play he was he was shot he was
on his way to buy a car with $50,000 in
cash and somebody shot him and took the
money which is very tragic I think also
it would be a very good venmo commercial
I mean that's that's the joke yeah
that's pretty funny
I mean it's unfortunate the guy died
it's like if you tell a joke with JFK
and bro he's dead exactly it's like it's
like it's like people people frame this
into this thing to about like it becomes
racial it becomes like you know it
becomes about this white girl she's
Indian she's yeah but yeah yeah but she
looks white enough to me but also okay
so she's Indian who who knows that who
who's gonna know that like if she if she
wanted to look Indian she'd look Indian
yeah okay so though I don't want to hear
that if I close my eyes what do I hear I
hear a white girl okay
and that's what people around the
country that they don't know they don't
even know her name and then you add that
element to it so what is that supposed
to mean and that's why I say people want
to know what you are so they can know
how to hate you like I'm all for her not
saying like she shouldn't say what she
is everything it's like no I'm just a
person making a funny joke right you
know but I think she should if I were
her I would I would go even further and
I double down I was not with you gonna
be dirty barrel I would be the dirt with
Dina Hashim and she makes do jokes that
throat that
just completely no-holds-barred exactly
I would do and she would have a career
for herself yes she could be the next on
who was the big lady they got skin that
all out of all about no the big lady
they gots thin thin in a very low okay
she did the roast Lisa Lampanelli that's
who I meant once she lost all that
weight yeah
disappeared bra well Weiss I don't know
she's like baby Jessica brush she
[ __ ] fell off the face of the earth
brother so what did James Davis say so
he was just like the first one that kind
of brought the joke to light and was
like this wasn't wrong this is wrong and
made a big stir about it and everybody
was criticizing him for attacking
another comment I agree with that though
he could games yeah I like James too but
I feel like this is one of these things
works like this is like one of those
things it's like what are we doing right
now
I mean if we're gonna like if I'm gonna
criticize her at all it's gonna be like
what cuz I'm not a fan of this type of
comedy this kind of like slow you know
right I was like boring yeah that's
boring to me that's not we see that for
an hour's a writer yeah but it's a
well-crafted joke I mean kudos you know
but it's just like that's that kind of
smug [ __ ] that Comedy Central wants to
put you know you have to watch that for
half hour and be like you're supposed to
be like oh is this gonna be the next
like like I'll come at ya like funny is
not a thing anymore like I so for some
reason it's not important to be funny or
entertaining like is that entertaining
like like that's the kind of joke where
you see it and you're supposed to go
like this oh well done my yeah you know
that's not I want to be like ah good I
want people to be like if you perform
away myself
if you perform it in a certain way
people gonna be like that's [ __ ] up
yeah but they they they they appreciated
what you did that was just more for the
shock value if she's a right way it was
presented I'm saying but I am mad at her
I'm just telling you know what's her
name Dena Hashim Dena passion putting
out there to you you ain't you did
alright keep doing you yeah you know
that's the chances we have to take yeah
and also yeah and James I mean I've
heard from people in me
eating's ever from people just on the
street that James Davis is hard to work
with
I've heard that repeatedly the young
man's hard to work with no huh
get him on the podcast yeah I'll have uh
left have him come on is he saying that
I've heard that I'm not saying that he's
a bad guy I'm not saying he's not funny
I'm just saying that I've heard that I
just wonder it's hard to say that about
you now they are I don't believe it I
believe but I'll say this you is now
enough to use the guy now on stage
complaining about it's too loud in the
hallway yeah that's how I knew you
changed that's when you change well the
place also Comedy Store no you change
the oh don't change that with two years
ago that wouldn't be the thing to you
would have just powered through
now you up there like up you bougie
[ __ ] what happened to you wrote
don't say what happened to you how many
story used to it used to be a lot I used
to run a lot more smoother I think it's
gotten chaotic out there bro last night
dude Joey Diaz on stage though likes
[ __ ] [ __ ] the whole time dude come on
it was [ __ ] before he went up there and
it's like y'all letting this man be up
there with that shitty mic well that's
something they got to take acid that's a
technical issue but every time the
technician dry he's out back smoking
dope keep working RadioShack on the off
days I think he knows how to work all
the equipment God
see what I'm saying you changed they got
now they got a stool over there where
the guy that by the window he used to
stand up and work now he's sitting over
there milling around brah hey I got
attacked at the Comedy Store so I get I
mean this is I'm just sayin stuff it's
been going on for a long time so I don't
know what to tell you but like a yeah I
think you should have James on I don't
know why I don't know why he did that I
just you know I just I would never I
don't know if I would ever come out
against a joking like this is wrong
right exactly what I'm saying - like
where's my mindset then yeah cuz insane
who who's allowed to say what that's not
the business we're in we are not in the
business of censorship right we're in
the business of taking chances and
sometimes when you take those chances
they're gonna go too
far and it's gonna be pushed back like
Kathy Griffin yeah that was a terrible
joke it was terrible and she's now
bounced back she's talking to you but
she made a documentary about everything
that's happened to her she's got a new
special coming out so that's what we
have to do where's this special oh I
don't I don't know probably um II
Netflix or something like that I'm not
sure but they have I girl that what I'm
saying that there's a push back after
but don't be coming out talking about
what summer can or cannot say my
criticism is technique you know what I
mean right
but like I get there the structure yeah
if somebody had a joke I would never be
like oh I might think to myself oh I
don't like that joke or what exactly but
that's how I feel about things like oh I
didn't like that that's not my cup of
tea that's not that's how I look at
stuff I don't I don't ever I'm just
never like I just can't my I don't I I
wouldn't have said it like that that's
all it is you know I still try to enjoy
people much time I don't ever even
common are we only we don't even usually
talk about this stuff but I thought it
would be interesting you brought it up
you know yeah and why just know
everybody's been talking about it
recently yeah though I thought it would
be interesting but it is one of those
things that's gonna blow all think about
together it's gonna blow up well it
nobody cares we won't even put the clip
up it's so blown over yeah yeah Wow you
know what's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options watch one this
one